[Musique]
bonjour messieurs dames bonjouronjour
est-ce que vous connaissez la rue agès
Sorel àoche non pas du tout alors la rue
agnè Sorel oui elle est un petit peu en
retrait du centre si je me souviens bien
et alors annè sorelle c'est qui euh
c'est la favorite du roi c'est une femme
très connue dans la
région c'est une dame de beauté alors
agè Sorel évidemment le sein découvert
la favorie
oui c'est vrai c'est une je crois une
des premières maîtresses à être
intronisée on en a besoin en ce moment
d'avoir des images de femme qui
valorisent bah les communes qui
valorisent des actions et avec tout ce
qui se passe c'est important avoir des
femmes des modèles de
femmes agè Sorel est la demoiselle de
compagnie d'Isabelle de laorine Duchesse
d'enjou vers 1443 elle attire
l'attention du roi ro Charles VI de 20
ans son aîné très vite Agnès Sorel
devient la favorite officielle du
roi son arrivée apporte un vent de
fraîcheur et de modernité qui ne fait
pas l'unanimité à la cour elle doit
faire face aux hostilités de certains
notamment du Dauphin Louis futur Louis X
elle donnera trois filles officiellement
reconnu au roi Charles VI signe de son
attachement le roi lui offre des fièvres
de beauté d'où le nom de dame de beauté
dont le domaine de l'oche situé dans la
vallée de la Loire et qui devient l'une
de ses résidences
préférées l'église où repose le tombeau
d'Agnès Sorel est devenu pour certains
le lieu d'un pèlerinage singulier dans
le paysage des châteaux de la
[Musique]
Loire
je vais à la rencontre de Madame
Augustine personnage tout à fait
singulier vous allez le découvrir et que
vous pouvez croiser au détour d'une rue
dans cette belle cité de
loche bonjour madame Augustine bonjour
alors que nouveau cette magnifique
toilette c'est mes vêtements quotidiens
vous exercez la profession de créatrice
couturière et costumière j'ai les deux
métiers c'est ça vous êtes une
passionnée de l'élégance dentant exact
vous avez d'ailleurs collaboré à la
confection de la robe agès Sorel dans le
cadre d'Octobre Rose vous pouvez nous en
parler on a voulu reproduire avec
Sandrine et plusieurs artisans de de
l'oche le tableau de Jean Fouquet où agè
Sorel a son sein àarent parce que
c'était pour le cancer du sein la lutte
contre le cancer du sein le tableau va
être mis aux enchères euh l'année
prochaine les femmes de cette époque je
crois vous ont particulièrement marqué
les femmes de toutes toute époque m'ont
marqué parce que c'est des souvent c'est
des femmes qui ont été si elles ont fait
des choses un peu extraordinaires qui
sortent de la maternité ou du rôle de
femme au foyer ça c'est souvent oublié
sous les tapis donc on a oublié les les
femmes qui sont battues les femmes qui
ont eu des rôles politiques les femmes
artistes ou artisanes tout simplement et
pourquoi c'est important que le tombeau
d'agè Sorel soit ici dans la commune de
looche parce que c'est sa ville avant
toute chose et parce qu'elle a elle a
marqué son temps quand on pense à l'oche
on pense automatiquement à ni et pas
d'autres personnes donc c'est important
qu'elle repose icion en tout cas merci
beaucoup vive l'élégance la créativité
ou chacune la sienne pour moi ce serait
plutôt des fleurs des couleurs des cœurs
et même pas
[Musique]
peur